[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo avec cette question cette
semaine
l'union européenne est elle un acteur
clé dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique nous irons en
suède
connaissez-vous le flic scam la honte de
prendre l'avion
par crainte de la pollution a de plus en
plus de suédois boycott l'avion et
préfère se déplacer en train pour
sauvegarder la planète
notre reportage à stockholm à le climat
au coeur des préoccupations européennes
vous le savez la banque européenne
d'investissement a annoncé qu'elle
cesserait de financer de nouveaux
projets liés aux énergies fossiles y
compris le gaz à partir de 2022
une décision saluée pour sa contribution
à la lutte contre le changement
climatique
et cette question cette question faut-il
taxer le kérosène des avions pour
financer la transition énergétique
c'est le débat en deuxième partie
d'émission de l'actualité c'est cette
respiration
la présidente de la commission respire
l'elysée respire ça passe pour la
candidature de thierry breton valider ou
après l'échec de sylvie goulard
les eurodéputés ont donné leur feu vert
à thierry breton pour qu'il devienne le
nouveau commissaire européen au marché
unique et au numérique on regarde un
résumé de cette audition et ont réagi
juste après
[Musique]
le pas décidé thierry breton est prêt
pour son audition il se sait attendu
surtout des députés européens
d'opposition et des accusations de
conflit d'intérêts si vous entriez en
fonction vous prendriez la tête d'un
portefeuille qui couvrirait à la fois la
politique industrielle
le numérique la défense l'espace et le
marché intérieur
vous conviendrez que c'est un pouvoir
immense comme il est aussi le trouble
qui nous habite
car il se trouve que l'entreprise que
vous aviez dirigé jusqu'il ya peu est
active dans l'ensemble des domaines que
je viens de citer et on voit le parfait
chevauchement entre ces différentes
ces différents secteurs telles garanties
et quel engagement concret pouvez vous
nous donner que vous défendrez l'intérêt
général plutôt que les intérêts privés
la réponse du commissaire désignée je
n'ai plus aucun intérêt dans les
entreprises que j'ai dirigé quand on a
eu plusieurs vies en une vie et que l'on
peut se présenter devant vous ici et
aujourd'hui c'est que la notion de
conflit d'intérêts et à l'éthique est un
sujet que l'on porte au plus profond de
soi
sur ce point précis je n'irai pas par
quatre chemins il n'y a qu'une solution
être radical je dis bien radicale avec
toujours le seul intérêt général en tête
exclusivement uniquement en toute
indépendance
je me présente donc devant vous
aujourd'hui sans plus aucun intérêt
patrimonial dans aucune entreprise ça
signifie très précisément que j'ai vendu
par le biais du marché toutes les
actions que j'ai possédé
avant même de me présenter à vous j'ai
aussi démissionné de tous ses mandats je
dis bien tous thierry breton s'est voulu
le plus transparent possible
c'est pour des raisons d'intégrité que
les eurodéputés avaient rejeté la
candidature de sylvie goulard cette fois
l'audition s'est davantage concentré sur
le groupe non politique
thierry breton postule pour un très
vaste portefeuille pendant la politique
industrielle le marché intérieur le
numérique la défense et l'espace
cette fois c'est passé les députés
européens ont validé la candidature au
poste de commissaire européen de thierry
breton
il a reçu les votes en sa faveur de la
droite du groupe aux sceptiques au crd
socialiste et enfin des centristes
d'euronews ursula von der leyen peut
respirer
la nouvelle commission censée au départ
entrée en fonction le 1er novembre
espère finalement commencé le 1er
décembre sauf nouveau rebondissement
la nouvelle présidente de la commission
devrait pouvoir se mettre son collège de
commissaires au vote du parlement
européen le 27 novembre
[Musique]
alors nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
petra de sutter bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputés belges 1 du groupe des verts
ici au parlement européen avoue présidé
la commission marché intérieur et
protection du consommateur au sein de ce
parlement vous allez donc être amené à
travailler avec le nouveau commissaire
au marché intérieur dcri
thierry breton si éric breton sera-t-il
un bon commissaire européen je vous
dirai dans cinq ans quand on aura le
bilan de ce qu'il a fait c'est vrai que
c'est un candidat très fort c'est un
portefeuille très importants comme on
l'a entendu dans le film c'est ce que
madame von der leyen voulait c'est ce
que le président macron vous laisser un
portefeuille qui combine quand même
beaucoup de compétences pour mettre
l'europe vraiment sur l'avant plan de
nouveau dans le monde
en compétition avec les marchés chinois
américain et c'est donc c'est une une
stratégie vraiment vue et l'audition
était sûr plus sur le fond un du
portefeuille plus que sur les conflits
d'intérêts
oui c'est vrai sur les conflits
d'intérêts la situation et c'est quand
même différente de celle de madame
goulard il a vendu tous ses intérêts
toutes ses actions et ses dents les
compagnies il a promis qu'il allait
vraiment être indépendant alors pour les
verts quand même parce que vous avez
vous savez j'ai deux chariots voilà un
casque est oui deux casquettes c'est ça
pour les verts le principe qu'on sort
d'une industrie pour immédiatement après
réguler cette même industrie est quand
même le numérique et atos etc
vous avez vu le schéma ça nous a fait
réfléchir si vraiment c'est une bonne
idée donc ça pour nous pour les verts il
ya beaucoup de réticences et on va être
très critique envers ce que le nouveau
commissaire monsieur breton va faire
d'enfin là dans sa politique à venir et
à les produits sains cliente sur le
marché européen seront abordés dans
votre commission sur quoi vous allez
être attentives pour commencer le marché
interne doit être renforcée c'est ce que
tout le monde dit parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de fragmentation il ya des
nouveaux obstacles des barrières que les
les états membres en fait mettre en
place donc on n'est pas vraiment dans
une évolution vers un marché complété il
ya encore beaucoup de travail à faire
surtout dans le domaine des services et
en plus est au dessus de tout ça il ya
le numérique qui arrive donc il faudra
mettre là
la réglementation en place qui de
nouveau et said épouse et tous les
avantages économiques et industrielles
dans la politique que madame van der
linde et monsieur bretons voudront faire
avancer et de façon à protéger les gens
à être sûr qu'il n'y a pas des intérêts
qui sont qui sont en danger donc pour
trouver cette balance il faudra vraiment
bien travaillé ensemble et le parlement
sera très critique surtout dans les
aspects comme je vous ai dit qu'ils
touchent à la donner est ce que les
données que les gens enfin dans le
digital bien sûr dans tous les secteurs
est-ce qu'ils appartiennent aux gens et
ce qu'on peut l'est les marchandises
qu'on peut les vendre qui peut les
employés sous quelles conditions et
c'est vraiment un chantier qui est tout
à fait nouveau et en plus l'article
intelligence artificielle qui s'ajoute
dont on n'a pas encore de cadre
réglementaire vous savez que la
commission a promis mahmoud blind dans
les 100 premiers jours je viendrai avec
un cadre éthique et légal pour regarder
ses aspects de l'intelligence
artificielle qui sera très importante ça
se seront quand même vraiment les
challenge de nous comme vous l'avez
abordé l'obsolescence programmée des
machines est ce qu'on va vers une
interdiction ne se sera pas si simple
que ça parce qu'il faut prouver que ces
programmes et que c'est voulu bien sûr
quand ou pas quand on parle avec les
producteurs les industries vont nous
donner d autres explications
moi je pense qu'il y aura une autre
évolution très intéressante à observer
c'est l'évolution où on passe des
produits au service
l'exemple classique c'est on n'achète
plus une lampe on achète la lumière et
donc le producteur le vendeur de lumière
où il aura bien sûr tout intérêt à ce
que la lampe continuer à brûler plus
longtemps donc les les produits qu'on va
mettre sur les marchés ils vont
peut-être dans toute l'idée de
l'économie circulaire et de la
durabilité dont on doit faire bon qui
est très important bien sûr dans dans
tous nos agendas du green deal et de
l'écologie qu'il faut bien c'est bien
sûr poussé je pense qu'on est tous
convaincu la commission aussi pour la
première fois il ya le green deal dans
l'agenda
oui comme justement
le gist vous avez double casquette à
président de la commission et
eurodéputée verte
quid de la politique verte va-t-on
investir vers les technologies de
transition de nouveau le message est
double on est très contents que c'est
vraiment si haut sur l'agenda de la
commission mais on va regarder si les
ambitions vont être réalisés parce que
quand même c'est pas madame von der
leyen seul ou monsieur timerman
et sûrement pas monsieur breton seuls
qui vont décider de ça c'est toute la
commision et c'est surtout les états
membres vous savez que on est des co
législateur avec les états membres et
c'est surtout les états membres
malheureusement qui bloque beaucoup
d'avancement dans ce domaine parce que
la lutte contre le changement climatique
chez nous voilà c'est très différent de
la pologne où on est encore complètement
submergée dans le charbon
donc pour décarboniser la grande grande
différence entre les états membres et
pour les aligner ce sera un grand
travail
donc on espère on est très positif quand
on regarde sur papier ce que la
commission veut faire mais il faudra
regarder ce qui va se réaliser en sera
le chalenge de ses premières années là
on reste sur la transition écologique et
direction la suède aux pays de greta
tune berg volet n'a plus le vent en
poupe un mouvement fait son chemin c'est
le flic scam la honte de prendre l'avion
regardez notre reportage à stockholm et
on en débat juste après avec nos invités
[Musique]
c'est le phénomène à la mode en suède le
flic scam a littéralement la honte de
prendre l'avion pour les suédois pour
eux voler est devenu trop polluants
aéroport arlanda de stockholm
nous sommes allés demander aux voyageurs
s'il avait honte de prendre l'avion eric
woerth à dos et portugais ce chorégraphe
doit se rendre souvent dans les
capitales aux quatre coins de la planète
pour se produire
il en a conscience c'est pas très
écologique je sais très bien que mon
bilan carbone et le
augmente j'ai fait les calculs mon bilan
carbone est bon il est très bon même et
après quand on rajoute l'avion en fait
il devient très mauvais mélissa et
canadiennes même si elle se dit qu'il
faudrait un jour repenser notre façon de
voyager
impossible pour elle d'abandonner
l'avion aujourd'hui je suis en semaine
donc
et puis c'est impossible pour moi de
voyager entre est par exemple de
montréal asss à stockholm donc j'aurais
pu prendre le bateau même si nos
voyageurs étrangers sont plutôt
réticents à l'idée d'abandonner l'avion
les suédois eux sont plus catégoriques
caroline à 34 ans est directrice des
ressources humaines
elle ramène le petit dernier oscar de la
crèche cet été sa petite famille
visitera le sud de l'europe n'est pas
question de prendre l'avion
le voyage se fera entre 1 je sais que ça
va prendre plus de temps
mais d'un autre côté on verra du pays un
peu plus si on va en allemagne ça va
nous prendre 20 heures en train au lieu
d'une heure en avion mais ce sera plus
enrichissant apprendre à ne plus prendre
l'avion et redécouvrir les joies du
train andreas on est convaincu c'est
comme cela aussi qu'on sauvera la
planète sur sa page facebook
tag ces masters on se recommandent des
itinéraires en train depuis cinq ans
déjà
ici un internaute propose le trajet
suède thaïlande
plusieurs mois de voyage et ça marche le
nombre de membres sur facebook est monté
en flèche
[Musique]
on est 100 mille membres aujourd'hui au
moins la moitié disent qu'ils veulent
moins prendre l'avion ou arrêter
totalement on peut voir qu'en allemagne
ils vont réduire les taxes pour voyager
en train on devrait s'inspirer en suède
avec andré h nous déciderons ensuite de
prendre la température en gare de
stockholm les gardes dites-moi est-ce
que vous avez honte de prendre l'avion
c'est sympa de prendre le train mais
personnellement je préfère prendre
l'avion c'est quand même plus facile
pour le climat personnellement je
préfère prendre le train
la frégate et un téléphone non je n'ai
pas honte de prendre l'avion je dois
partir en vacances à tenerife bientôt
[Rires]
[Musique]
même si les vieilles habitudes restent
difficiles à changer renoncer à l'avion
c'est une tendance qui prend de
l'ampleur pour preuve le nombre de
passagers utilisant le train a
littéralement explosé
[Musique]
on a sept millions de passagers en train
en plus aujourd'hui comparé à il ya cinq
ans rien que l'année dernière on a une
augmentation d'un million et demi de
passagers 5000 nouveaux passagers chaque
jour en moyenne
et ça ne fait qu'augmenter avec cette
année 7000 nouveaux passagers chaque
jour
ce jour-là 8000 jeunes manifestants sont
rassemblés dans le centre de stockholm
une grande manifestation conduite par le
mouvement créé des sports futur objectif
exiger une action contre le
réchauffement climatique
une invitée surprise en visioconférence
depuis new york
greta tune bergues c'est l'icône du
mouvement mondial pour le climat
après quinze jours de traversée de
l'atlantique à bord d'un voilier zéro
émission carbone s'il vous plaît la
jeune suédoise de 16 ans est à l'onu
pour défendre le climat en militante
infatigable maya rosen trac ce jour là
elle a lancé une campagne sur internet
il ya quelques mois
we stay on the ground on reste au sol
son objectif faire en sorte que cent
mille personnes ne prennent pas l'avion
pendant un an
et ça marche plus de 12000 personnes ont
déjà signé la pétition en ligne
aujourd'hui nous avons dix ans pour
réduire nos émissions de co2 de moitié
on ne peut plus continuer à prendre
l'avion comme on fait voler c'est la
plus grosse source d'émissions de gaz
pour nous en tant qu'individu donc en
abandonnant l'avion on peut faire un
grand bond en avant pour le climat que
disent les scientifiques c'est que si on
ne réduit pas les émissions de gaz
maintenant on risque de ne plus avoir de
futures je veux dire j'ai deux enfants
et je ne sais même pas s'ils pourront
atteindre mon âge à mike
pour la première fois en dix ans le
trafic aérien est en baisse en suède
dans un pays où l'on prend cinq fois
plus l'avion que la moyenne mondiale
renoncer à ce type de transport n'était
pas évident et le modèle suédois risque
d'être contagieux
[Musique]
voilà pour notre reportage en suède nous
on choix sur ce plateau dominique riquet
bonjour vous êtes aux députés du groupe
renault ou renouvelés l'europe a le
groupe du parlement européen où siègent
les députés français de renaissance à la
liste soutenue par la république en
marche merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation karima delli
bonjour vous êtes dans vos députés du
groupe les verts président de la
commission transports ici au parlement
européen merci d'être venu enfin pierre
larrouturou
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes économiste eurodéputés du
groupe socialiste et démocrate un élu en
mai dernier sur la liste place publique
alors vous venez de voir ce reportage
est ce qu'il faut avoir honte de prendre
l'avion pour protéger la planète lutter
contre la pollution dominique riquet non
il faut pas avoir honte mais simplement
c'est le moyen de transport le plus
adapté pour certaines distances et
certaines destinations
il faut pas le prendre quand il ya des
moyens alternatifs qui sont aussi
performants je pense que 21ème siècle
comme les autres succèdent aux progrès
de déplacement qui est une des grandes
libertés des hommes simplement il faut
pas prendre l'avion quand le tracé là
même où la meilleure performance qu'à
rival karima delli oui je le dis à
dernière chose c'est que en kilomètre
passager co2 les bills avion c'est
plutôt meilleur que transporter karima
delli faut pas avoir honte de prendre
l'avion alors moi je crois que les
citoyens une vraie conscience c'est
qu'ils savent qu'il nous reste dix ans
étudiant votre reportage ils veulent
faire un geste concret leur geste
concret c'est de dire on arrête l'avion
va pas les punir
moi je trouve que c'est un geste très
fort maintenant et c'est vrai il faut
des alternatives donc il faut renforcer
les trains et notamment les trains de
nuit
maintenant la véritable question c'est
que ce secteur ne fait qu'augmenter
alors si certains pays on voit au cul ça
régresse l'aviation en général depuis 20
ans augmenter de 150% et si on fait une
projection d'ici 2050
il va encore augmenter puisque
aujourd'hui à l'échelle européenne c'est
5% d'ici à ce que c'est pas le signe
d'une démocratisation civ
non parce en fait tout est vrai et
j'aurais aimé de vous dire que notamment
les plus pauvres freine lavion non 80%
et des ouvriers des classes populaires
ne prennent pas l'avion
ceux qui prennent l'avion ce sont les
plus riches donc à un moment il faut
aussi que nous en tant que responsables
politiques comprennent l'aviation comme
les autres secteurs et on le fasse
contribuer dans la dans le réchauffement
climatique c'est pour ça que
r qu'on aura demain une taxe kérosène on
va en parler pierre larrouturou sur le
flic scam la honte de prendre l'avion
tout à fait d'accord est ce que vient de
dire karima c'est pas un prime de honte
c'est juste un point de responsabilité
c'est à dire que a priori on ne prend
plus l'avion ce qu'on a compris la
gravité du problème
je sais pas si on peut faire un zoom là
dessus il ya encore des gens qui pensent
qu on a 20 ans ou 30 ans ça c'est une
courbe qui montre l'évolution de la
fonte des glaces au groenland depuis
trente ans la courbe en bleu c'est la
moyenne en moyenne à la fin de l'été
quand il fait très chaud très chaud il y
avait seulement 20% de la glace qui
avait fondu mais cette année c'est la
courbe en rouge
il y avait déjà la moitié de la glace du
groenland qui avait fondu en juillet
donc on est vraiment prêt d'un point
d'effondrement les climatologues nous
disent que le problème est en train de
s'aggraver
et quand la glace fond il ya de moins en
moins de surface blanche pour envoyer la
chaleur il ya des cercles vicieux donc
les climatologues ça fait 40 ans qui
nous alertent ils disent il est encore
possible de gagner la bataille il encore
possible d'éviter le chaos mais il faut
réduire de façon drastique de fait
divisé par deux nos émissions de co2 il
ya des secteurs où c'est compliqué il ya
des secteurs où c'est facile
moi je vais à madrid dans deux semaines
pour le sommet sur le climat on ira en
train il faut changer de mode de vie
avoir un mot du mode de vie moins excité
avoir du temps pour soi et on peut
prendre le train et se dire que l'avion
c'est exceptionnel donc aux questions
fondamentales sur sur le sujet ce qu'il
faut taxer le le le kérosène des avions
pour financer la transition écologique à
valhalla votre question voilà il faut
taxi mais pourquoi moi je pense que si
effectivement la taxe ou des
prélèvements sur les moyens de transport
polluants ou sur les émissions
elle est affectée à réduire les
émissions c'est à dire à favoriser la
recherche développement des nouvelles
technologies des modes de transports
alternatifs alors là oui
donc je pense qu' il faudrait
effectivement taxés il faudrait aussi
affecter la taxe à un objet qu'ils
soient écologiques
karima delli ah ben moi j'ai support la
taxe kérosène il est grand temps parce
que le kérosène c'est quand même la
seule énergie fossile qui n'est pas
taxée par rapport à tous les autres
quand même un scandale envoyez la crise
des gilet jaune ils se sont dit mais
pourquoi nous on paie pour notre petit
carburant alors que justement l'aviation
qui aimait énormément lui n'est pas
taxée de qu'il faut mettre en place la
taxe kérosène ça tombe bien
la commission européenne a fait une
étude est elle montre quoique 0
33 centimes de l'ide il marquait d'euros
par par centime par kilo mais ça revient
dans le budget européen de 27 milliards
27 milliards d'euros on peut oui
investir dans le train de nuit mais
c'est surtout le fait qu'il faut
considérer que le kérosène ne peut plus
être un paradis fiscal
parce que justement ça nous prive de
recettes pour être investi là où il faut
c'est à dire le tran huy où les
alternatives dans les différents on voit
bien à nous les petites gares etc vous
relancer tous au niveau européen parce
que le train c'est plutôt bon pour le
climat et ses meilleurs aussi pour
l'accès à nos territoires
hier la route ou est ce que est ce que
le risque c'est pas aussi que l'aviation
avait faire le plein à côté dans dominus
et moi taxés vous savez qu'au japon ou
même en arabie saoudite
il ya des taxes au canada mais s'il ya
des taxes même en arabie saoudite sur
les vols intérieurs et donc c'est quand
même ahurissant quelqu'un qui fait le
plein d'essence vois dans mon coin des
pyrénées la plupart des gens sont
obligés de prendre la voiture pour aller
au travail
quand vous faites le plein d'essence
vous avez 68 centimes de taxe en france
pour un litre d'essence 68 centimes est
par contre quand vous prenez l'avion
c'est karim à l'expliquer c'est zéro
centime zéro centime sur le kérosène
zéro centime de tva c'est absolument
choquant et d'en essayer et du coup le
train est plus cher que l'avion
si vous voulez aller à madrid depuis
paris la viande l'avion est moins cher
que le train c'est juste ridicule
donc oui il faut progressivement en un
an ou deux ans que le niveau de taxes
soit le même sur le kérosène que sur
l'essence normale et que cet argent
aille intégralement pour construire des
trains à nous mettre des trains grande
vitesse il ya des pays d'europe il n'y a
pas encore de trains grande vitesse pour
faire des trains de nuit pour améliorer
les dessertes dans les banlieues où nous
fait ou permettre le travail à distance
dans mon coin des pyrénées
peut-être qu'on n'est pas obligé d'aller
cinq jours par semaine à argelès ou à
lourdes pour aller au boulot s'ils
avaient dû du haut débit si on pouvait
travailler à distance peut être
comprendrez seulement deux fois par
semaine allez voir les collègues et que
trois jours par semaine on pour rester
dans le village dont il ya un besoin
d'investissement massif
les citoyens sont prêts les entreprises
les collectivités et on a besoin de
financement donc la taxe et rozenn c'est
une priorité car i maladie ces prêts
techniquement il n'y a aucun problème
il ya juste le lobby de l'avion qui
résiste il faut qu'un lobby citoyens et
des députés qui disent on avance en
avance et ça m'évite de l'avion qui
résistent dominique riquet deux
remarques
premièrement actuellement les mécanismes
budgétaire en europe et en france ne
permettent pas d'affecter rip taxe à une
cible et je prends un exemple par
exemple les nombreuses taxes sur les
carburants terrestre sur l'essence
j'avais été affectés améliorer le réseau
routier dont on a vu qu'il pose quelques
problèmes je prends cet exemple là
deuxièmement effectivement le transport
aérien est taxé même très taxés en
france très taxée 38 % taxe sur le prix
des billets d'avion il n'est pas taxées
en fonction de ses performances
environnementales y aurait lieu de
regarder ça d'un peu plus près je pense
que le problème c'est qu'on va pas
retourner à la diligence
on doit favoriser le transport terrestre
qui est moins émetteur lorsqu'il est
performant et moi je suis désolé je
partage pas l'avis de kariba avec de
temps en temps c'est que c'est la
démocratisation qui a augmenté de loin
et notamment les compagnies low cost qui
a augmenté de loin le nombre de vols et
donc les émissions
il faudra trouver un moyen je pensais
que tak tak c'est donc évidemment ça va
profiter aux riches les taxant ça
profite à pori jetons je suis sûr que ça
va pénaliser les pipots pénaliser le
dérèglement climatique s'aggrave il ya
eu mille morts 1000 morts à cause du
cyclone ida 70 morts au jardin donc les
riches et les pauvres ils vont son
va-tout ce nom mais cette opposition là
je ne veux pas la faire ce que je veux
dire par là faire je suis d'accord pour
dire qu'il ya un problème de dérèglement
climatique
je suis d'accord pour dire qu'on doit
prendre les mesures qui sont adaptés je
dis simplement que ces mesures doivent
être commandés remarquer elles doivent
servir à ça ce hasard au nucléaire va
dessus que deuxièmement ils apprennent
de démocratisation qui existent on l'a
vu être les gilet jaune sur le terrestre
on le verrait dans l'aviation je pense
qu'il ya peut-être des mesures à prendre
différents sienne
voilà on est pas d accord sur le fond du
problème
j'attire simplement l'attention sur le
fait que si vous taxez affectés mais là
où ça doit les d'accord à 100%
deuxièmement prenez en considération le
fait que lorsque l'on taxe à d'affect
pas les gens de la même façon en
fonction de la ressource ok là on se
rabat ou non mais on est d'accord sur
une fiscalité
c'est écolo est acceptée si elle est
juste elle est juste ça veut dire aussi
prendre en compte les niveaux de vie
mais on voit bien que les chiffres sont
là les plus pauvres ne prennent pas
l'avion il préfère prendre le train de
faire du du tourisme de proximité
c'est ça alors c'est pas eux qui est
entre guillemets détruit de la planète
premièrement deuxième chose il faut voir
aussi que le texte qui osent end à avoir
des impacts sur les comportements
l'étude de la commission européenne
puisque vous parlez du lobby notamment
aériens qui dit attention ça va nous
coûter des emplois pas du tout ça ne
tuera pas d'emploi pierre l'a dit il ya
d'autres pays le japon les etats-unis la
norvège ils ont déjà est-ce que ça tu es
l'emploi non il faut dire que les grands
concurrents dans l'aviation c'est les
compagnies du golfe et ses les locos un
paris madrid 20 euros c'est quand même
un scandale
là on ne prend pas en compte l'impact
climatique et je terminerai par une
chose qui était important c'est la
démocratisation
je rappelle que en ce moment il y à une
initiative citoyenne c'est à dire une
pétition sur la taxe kérosène à les y
aider nous pour enfin la mettre en place
parce que 27 milliards d'euros
ça peut être vraiment des belles
alternatives pour avoir accès chacun
d'entre nous est une vraie mobilité
propre et accessible vous l'avez
certainement a appris à la banque
européenne d'investissement renonce à
financer les énergies fossiles à partir
de 2022
est ce que c'est une décision historique
dans la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
c'est une bonne nouvelle mois avec jean
jouzel le prix nobel de la paix avait
d'autres ça fait quatre ans qu'on se bat
pour avoir une banque du climat au début
on rigolait et maintenant tout le monde
dit que c'est une bande du climat on y
va donc c'est top c'est une bonne
nouvelle il y en a pas beaucoup donc
autant le dire mais ce n'est qu'un petit
pas parce que au mieux ça va faire 15
milliards de plus c'est très bien c'est
très bien ça fait 15 milliards de moins
chaque année pour les énergies fossiles
et 15 milliard de plus pour les
renouvelables
simplement je vous rappelle que si on
veut gagner la bataille si on veut
isoler toutes les maisons toutes les
écoles tous les théâtres toutes les
universités si on veut mettre des
transports en commun si on veut aider
les agriculteurs à changer
la commission européenne elle même dit
qu'il manque chaque année 400 milliards
il manque chaque année 400 milliards la
cour des comptes dit qu'il manque la can
et 1100 milliards donc c'est une bonne
nouvelle
ces 15 milliards mais c'est juste trente
fois trop petit donc c'est pour ça qu'on
se bat avec beaucoup de députés avec
beaucoup de haine j'ai beaucoup
d'associations pour
on veut un vrai traité sur le climat un
exemple un exemple concret au delà de la
taxe et rosette grand défend ensemble
c'est l'idée que la banque centrale
européenne vient d'annoncer qu'elle va
créer 240 milliards la bce a commencé le
1er novembre à relancer la machine à
billets 240 milliards
est ce qu'on les donne aux banques et on
sait que 90 % va à la spéculation
c'est le bilan qu'on fait du
quantitative easing depuis cinq ans et
on aura une crise financière terrible où
est ce qu'on se dit que c'est 240
milliards on l'aimé intégralement sur le
climat et sur l'emploi combien est-ce
qu'on peut isoler de maison avec 240
milliards combien on peut développer de
transport en commun et c'est très
concret la bce vient d'annoncer qu'elle
va créer 240 milliards en un an
c'est pour ça moi que dans le groupe
social démocrate je me bats pour dire
c'est pas dans quatre ans qu'il faut
réagir
cet argent où il ya un moment où c'est
juste évident est-ce que cet argent va
la spéculation ou est-ce qu'il va créer
des emplois en plus de chomage
recommencent à augmenter dans tous nos
pays depuis quelques semaines depuis
quelques mois karima delli vous avez
l'espoir que cette commission von der
leyen soit plus écolo que la précédente
celle de juncker alors tout le monde
aujourd'hui vous se veut écolo tant
mieux mais maintenant c'est bien de le
dire il faut agir et là j'ai un petit
problème de fond est ce qu'on va avoir
une réelle orientation de la pac parce
que la pâte tel qu'on l'a aujourd'hui
c'est un peu une agriculture
productiviste et qui a un qui a comme
effet malheureusement que nos propres
agriculteurs ne vivent pas de leur
travail et ces suicides
est-ce qu'on va avoir le cran de dire
stop aux accords de libre échange
on peut pas dire on défend le climat et
en même temps on fait le mercosur un
moment il faut pas choisir des ailes de
l'enregistrement pour certains et la
montée des températures pour tous c'est
pas possible
donc il faut des choix courageux est
maintenant temps que je vois rien que
sur les traités de libre échange etc
les choix ont été faits le parlement le
conseil et la commission dont elle vient
de se mettre d'accord sur le budget de
l'union 2020 a quand même si mam qui
permet d'investir 1 9 milliard alors le
climat et l'emploi des jeunes ces deux
nouvelles pas non pour l'instant c'est
on va dans le bon sens ce sont des choix
qui ont été aussi débattu ici au
parlement européen on peut pas avoir
juste justement le parlement aujourd'hui
européen une voix maintenant c'est bien
de dire qu'on a mis un peu plus pour le
climat mais non c'est que 1,9 milliard 1
c'est pas énorme de la fal europe plus
verte
l'europe à dire l'europe le bon
le monde en beer performances
écologiques en essayant de préserver au
maximum les intérêts des citoyens
les intérêts écologiques et la
transition économique qui est nécessaire
il faut aller beaucoup plus loin et
beaucoup plus vite j'étais celui qui est
négocié pour le groupe social-démocrate
le budget indique une 9 milliards c'est
mieux que rien mais c'est vraiment ces
deux cents fois trop faible ces deux
sens pas trop faible j'ai dit l'autre
jour au commissaire que j'allais voter
ce budget mais que c'était ridicule et
le commissaire oettinger a dit qu'elle
était d'accord c'est ridicule donc moi
j'aurais honte devant moi devant mes
amis devant mes enfants si dans l'année
qui vient on n'est pas quand ça pas de
changer de braquet
quand kennedy dit on va aller sur la
lune le budget de la nasa est multiplié
par 15 les comptables s'arrache les
cheveux mais kennedy c'est x 15 pour la
nasa qui crée quatre cent mille emplois
quand roosevelt arrive pour lutter
contre le chômage le budget fédéral des
etats-unis c'est x 3 et il met une taxe
sur les plus riches une taxe sur les
bénéfices et ciel et ça marche et
kennedy héros du ltd pas des malades
mentaux il avait un projet pour le pays
donc vraiment ce qu'on a fait jusqu'à
maintenant c'est juste le début ça va
dans le bon sens mais il faut changer
complètement de braquer paris il faut
que les citoyens nous aident vue
l'inertie du système il faut que les
citoyens nous aide
il faut que ça pousse qu'on pousse tous
ensemble donc un budget passé ambitieux
à coup sûr ce sera le mot de la fin
merci à vous trois d'être venus débattre
avec nous c'était très instructif
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis et
bonne suite des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires bail
[Musique]